after the pandemic 86 its original
release date fans have had to wait a
whole calendar year for f9 to make it to
the big screen but now the ninth fast
and furious film is here and its near
apocalyptic climax must be unpacked
most of the film's plot machinations
center around jacob's quest for power
stemming from his deep insecurity at
having to live for so long in his big
brother's shadow
but with this being a fast and furious
film you might not be surprised that
before the credits begin to roll this
chapter's central villain undergoes a
change of heart so broadly telegraphed
it may as well have been visible from
space
jacob's plan and that of his financier
auto is to gather the three pieces of a
top secret digital weapon called ares
it's a two-piece device that requires a
key to activate and a satellite uplink
to hijack anything in the world that
runs on code
jacob and otto kidnapped cipher the
twisted hacker from the fate of the
furious as mr nobody is transporting her
in the hopes of using cipher's expertise
to locate the missing half of aries
the key it turns out is a young woman
named elle whose deceased parents
designed aries
she's been in hiding under the care of
han whose apparent tragic death at the
end of the fast and the furious tokyo
drift is revealed to be one of mr
nobody's useful spycraft ruses
through a series of pyrotechnics car
chases and family reunions jacob's plan
succeeds in amassing the core parts of
aries but not before he drops a
devastating bombshell on his brother
dom disowned jacob years ago thinking
his baby brother was responsible for the
death of their father jack
but jacob reveals that jack enlisted his
help in rigging his car
the day of the race because he was
planning to throw it the toretto family
was in debt but jack couldn't bear the
thought of his favorite son seeing him
betray their values
jacob never intended to kill their
father and has even in jack's death been
protecting his big brother from this
truth
with those facts out in the open dom is
more open to reconciling with jacob
which is very convenient for when otto
betrays the younger toretto
siding with cypher and attempting to
take jacob off the board
in the heat of the film's elaborate
climax jacob whose sister mia has helped
him escape
returns to the fray to help his
brother's new family foiled the
world-shattering caper he himself
initially conceived
stopping otto's implementation of aries
on the ground with the toretto family
fully reunited is just one half of the
strategy while dom jacob mia and the
others try to bring down the armored
truck housing aries and stop it from
uploading its code to a satellite in
orbit
tej and roman have to thwart things on
the other side of the transfer in outer
orbit
space the final frontier
the idea that the gang would end up
traveling in space gets seeded early in
two key ways
firstly roman's arc throughout f9 is
vaguely meta-textual
as he becomes obsessed with how many
harrowing experiences a cast
collectively survives and how rarely
they wind up even lightly scarred
he begins to believe that maybe just
maybe they all might be in some way
invincible
at the same time tej and roman are sent
to germany to acquire wheels and gear
for the mission
and there they cross paths with a trio
of tokyo drift stars
sean twinkie and earl the trio now
developed cars that are
wouldn't you guess strapped with massive
rockets so when it comes time to try to
disable a satellite that ramsay can't
hack from the ground
roman and tedge have to suit up in
diving gear and duct tape and
subsequently blast off into space
but their original plan of frying the
satellite with an emp fails their only
remaining option is to destroy the
satellite with brute force
which would require them to use the last
of their rocket fuel to propel their
modded car ship through the craft
which would also strand them in space
with no way home this is where roman's
invincibility obsession comes into play
as he makes his peace with the idea that
either they will somehow miraculously
survive this ridiculous situation or
this will be their last stand
what better way to go out he posits than
to die in space
roman's thesis is essentially proven
correct when their hail mary play saves
the day and a foreign space crew finds
them and helps them back to earth
with the bad guys beaten and the toretto
family wounds beginning to heal things
can return to normal
or as normal as dom's gang can ever
truly have
throughout f9 mia and letty both
struggle with accepting time away from
the fast-paced lifestyle of their
previous movies
they're both mothers now two women who
have otherwise never had solo dialogue
together on all these films get time to
bond on screen in f9 and both find that
it's okay to no longer throw themselves
into the fray but agree that they can't
hide away from adventure when it comes
to their doorstep
when the whole gang gets together for
the obligatory corona sponsored cookout
at the old toretto home now being
rebuilt after the last film's
destruction the crew is back home in la
and no longer hiding abroad
they even leave a seat at the table for
brian o'connor whose car speeds up the
driveway just as the credits roll
after this there will be a fast ten two
parts of it in fact as deadline reports
as eventful as f9 is the film's
conclusion leaves a few tasty open
threads to be untangled in that
double-fisted finale
fast and furious this isn't a movie it's
tradition for the second film in a row
cypher gets away scot-free
while plenty of other antagonists in the
fast franchise have received redemption
arcs and second chances it's unlikely
that the woman who killed the mother of
dom's child is going to get off so
easily
as for han he is alive and back in the
fold but as a mid-credits teaser reminds
us he still has unfinished business with
deckard shaw
the man thought to be responsible for
his fake death and speaking of
redemption arcs jacob may have driven
off in a 10-second car
a last-minute gift from his big brother
dom but it's unlikely to be the last
we'll ever see of him
fans will simply have to wait and see
what happens next with any luck the 10th
franchise installment will arrive fast
and furious check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you